so ian was this expected give us the
background to all this yes it very much
was expected mark now of course jack
dorsey was one of three uh people who
founded uh the business back in 2006. he
was ousted previously as chief executive
back in 2008 when a previous board
director fred watson said that he was
unfit to lead the company uh twitter
then had a full-time ceo in dick
costello he left in 2015 and that was
when jack dorsey made his return now
since then twitter shares have risen by
some 85 percent not a bad performance
over six years you might think but
they've fallen by about a third during
the last six months and that has uh not
gone down terribly well with investors
now the other key factor here is that
jack dorsey is currently chief executive
of not one company but two he's also ceo
of square which is a fintech company
it's substantially bigger than twitter
twitter's market cap at the moment is
around 37 billion dollars while squares
market cap is some 97 billion dollars so
clearly if he was forced to choose
between one of those two companies he's
going to go for square the larger of the
two and that's a choice that a lot of
shareholders have been urging him to
make a couple of years ago he had a row
with elliot investment which is one of
the most feared activist investment
investors on the block they took a share
in the business they urged him to choose
between square and twitter at that time
he bought them off by giving them
boardroom representation along with
silverlake which is a big u.s private
equity company that was also agitating
for change but it seems that the main
obstacle really was coming up with a
successor for him they've now done that
they're replacing him with the chief
technology officer a share price having
risen by 10 as you said earlier that was
on reports of his departure it's now
only up one and a half percent